[说话人 1]
好的。我不太确定，因为我以前从未经历过，或者说已经经历过了，但我会
尝试向某人寻求帮助，对吧？能帮助我的人，因为我是个年长的人。所以
[说话人 1]
对我们来说，事情比年轻人更困难。所以我会的。
[说话人 2]
我们会寻求帮助。你会用电话给某人打电话，或者我们可以大声呼救。
[说话人 1]
是的。是的。如果那是当时的情况，我确实会求助。是的。
嗯，你可以说“救命”。“救命，快把我从洪水里弄出去。”
[说话人 1]
你知道，事情是这样的，那里就像静止了一样，因为那是个隧道，它有，
在它的最末端，有像更高点的地方。所以洪水正好从中间
[说话人 1]
涌入隧道，然后流出隧道。
[说话人 2]
就像一个水坑。
[说话人 1]
是的。它不像一个你真的可以去游泳的池子。是的。我会抱有希望。我确实会寻求帮助。
那就是我会做的，你知道，或者如果我找不到帮助，
[说话人 1]
我会开始跑，并试图抓住我周围的东西，这样我就不会，你知道，陷入
洪水中，并试图从那里逃脱。
[说话人 2]
如果发洪水了，我会游泳，因为我会游泳，
但是你会游泳吗？
[说话人 1]
只会一点点。我一尝试游泳就会抽筋，所以
我尽量不那么做，因为那会变得很糟糕。
[说话人 2]
如果你不是非得如此，你就不会尝试。
[说话人 1]
是的。尤其是那水，那洪水，我的意思是，在那部分有点脏。
城市一些地方的污水和垃圾很多都排向那里。所以我认为，
[说话人 1]
那是不值得推荐的。
[说话人 2]
我想一个更好的假设情景是和你的家人待在一个好地方，
一个你安全并且只是去获取食物的地方。
[说话人 2]
那听起来像是完美的假设情景。
[说话人 1]
是的，我希望我能比那更安全。
[说话人 2]
这里有一个问题。我们已经看了一些常见的开场白
和假设性问题。让我们试着把这些与你自己的想法
[说话人 2]
和潜在的对话，即你喜欢谈论的事情联系起来。
所以我们可以回顾一下我们已经有过的这些开场白和假设性
[说话人 2]
问题，并思考一下最有趣的提问类型以及我们如何在真实对话中
回答另一个问题。你会在什么样的情况下使用这些类型的问题？
[说话人 2]
让我们试着把这个再分类一下。之前，我给你们看了一张
这些不同问题的列表。第一个问题是，“你曾经去过的最有趣的地方是哪里，
[说话人 2]
是什么让它与众不同？”如果你回答了那个问题，
你会在对话中什么时候问这个问题？
[说话人 1]
什么样的情况下？
嗯，我会问一个我最近认识的人。我们开始对话，
[说话人 1]
就像为了打破僵局一样，对吧？而且为了打破僵局，我会开始一段对话，
告诉对方，嗯，如果我看到他们对那种类型的对话感兴趣的话。
[说话人 1]
但是，你知道，当你被介绍给某人或向某人介绍自己时，谈论自己是很常见的事情，
对吧？而且你在寻找问题或者，你知道，
[说话人 1]
你可以讲述的经历。
[说话人 2]
有一个你能回答的问题是很好的，
因为那样你就知道你能说什么。但如果你也能这样问对方一个问题，
[说话人 2]
那对对方也有帮助。这能让对话进行得更
顺畅。双方都能从中受益。
[说话人 1]
是的。尤其是我回答的那个问题，
也就是第一个，因为，你知道，你会开始谈论你的工作地点，
[说话人 1]
对吧？如果他们问我，我在哪里工作过？那么我会告诉他们在机场。
所以他们会问我是否经常旅行，因为作为机场员工，
[说话人 1]
他们会开始问那样的问题。我曾经在一家非常小的航空公司工作，
对，那家公司只在，只在国内运营本地航班。所以我过去常常谈论
[说话人 1]
我们的岛屿，圣佩德罗苏拉，那是我们国家北部的一个地方。而那只是
为了打破僵局和开始对话。我通常，或者谈论他们的家庭，
[说话人 1]
他们来自哪里，以及所有那些类似的事情。只是为了打破僵局。总是那老一套。
[说话人 2]
这是你对自己非常自在的事情。你用英语进行过很多这样的
对话。所以如果我们稍微需要走出舒适区一点，
[说话人 2]
也许我们可以问这些问题中的另一个。好的。如果你除了第一个问题之外，
再选择一个问题，你会选择哪个问题？你会在什么时候问这个问题？
[说话人 2]
[说话人 1]
好的。让我再读一遍。告诉我一个你克服的挑战。
你从中学到了什么？在不久的将来，你期待什么？
[说话人 1]
你有什么别人可能会觉得惊讶的爱好或活动？好的。其中一件事
就是找到一份新工作。那是我的挑战之一，因为即使我是个年长的人，
[说话人 1]
但我需要养活自己。我不习惯被别人供养。
我一直都是养家糊口的人，所以我需要自己找份工作。这对我来说一直很困难也很有挑战性，
[说话人 1]
因为正如我告诉过你的，我是个年长的人，而且你知道，在我的国家，像我这样的人
或者其他与我同龄的人的机会并不多，诸如此类。
[说话人 1]
但是，你知道，我准备得越充分，我就越快能找到工作，对吧？但即使你学习了很多，
有时并且有很多经验，在这个国家那也是不够的，因为
[说话人 1]
你和那些为我们可能申请的那种工作做好了充分准备的年轻人之间有很多竞争。
[说话人 2]
听到这如此具有挑战性，我真的很难过。
我知道在很多地方，年长者找到平等机会都是一个挑战。
[说话人 2]
但是仅仅和你交谈了几次，上了几节课之后，我真的能看出你拥有
一些非常棒的沟通技巧。你有一些令人印象深刻的经验。如果我是雇主，
[说话人 2]
我会对你的简历和经验非常感兴趣。你有很多很棒的东西可以提供，
在洪都拉斯找机会可能会遇到问题，但我认为
[说话人 2]
你在其他地方找机会不会有任何问题。我想你
能做到。你只需要相信自己。你拥有一些非常棒的技能和沟通
[说话人 2]
技巧。我对您的语言表达能力印象非常深刻。